[Music]
their business is steel
the company founder Augustin built his
Empire up from scratch
some Fritz smooth the Nazis path to
power
when Fritz subsequently broke with the
regime Hitler sent him to a
concentration camp
[Music]
thrived
thrived The Heirs would be and nobled by
immeasurable wealth as the most
significant art collector of his day
Hans heinlished created an everlasting
Monument
to this day the name is legendary
[Music]
a house with one kilometer of lakefront
Villa Favorita in lugana was once the
residence of Hans heinrichterson
bonamisa and home to his International
High Society Patchwork family
foreign
than anywhere else in the world it was
as wonderful as a child and the big
Terrace where we always used to have
lunch outside with my dad and especially
then he would go and they would be
literally they would be sitting there
waiting for the moment he'd go he'd pull
out the kingdom anybody want to go to
the gallery because you were absolutely
dead and buried if you'd say oh I got
better a headache I think I got some boy
you were never invited again you know so
I was like yes please honey
[Music]
was known was not only master of a
gigantic industrial Empire he was also
passionate about art but he was somebody
who needed buying like a fix I mean it
was every first January each year he
would say to himself that he would stop
buying but by the sixth or 7th of
January the latest
that uh intention was overridden
the heir to the Tucson Empire owned the
most important private art collection in
the world he loved exhibiting his
paintings of villa favarita not only for
family and friends but also for the
public
heinitisen's fifth wife was a Spanish
woman by the name of Carmen cervera she
was known as Tita
[Music]
Tita a former Miss Spain was a film
actress
she met the multi-billionaire who was 22
years her senior in the early 1980s
um
it was the beginning of a fateful Affair
Tito wanted to get her hands on her
husband's billions to do so she had to
drive a wedge between heinitussin and
his children
she was winding him up against everybody
and that's actually when we were not
allowed to see my father anymore I mean
I have so much evidence
that this woman manipulated every single
situation that she could by 1997 she had
him where she wanted him I need to
ensued his children for whom he had set
up a Family Trust based in Monaco
the stakes were high an inheritance
comprising around 200 companies in over
20 countries
[Music]
was the climax of a tragic family
dispute there could only be one winner
Harbor any anger about her but on the
other hand I will never
forgive her
the original Source from which all the
money flowed is situated in the city of
duisburg here the story of the tison
group began 120 years ago August Tucson
secretly became the majority shareholder
in a coal mine
below ground coal was mined above ground
he built steel Works under Mill the
integrated Iron and Steel Works was
August Justin's greatest idea Augustus
August system built an Empire that
covered everything from the raw material
to the finished product
to produce Iron and Steel he needed coal
ore and water he began buying up coal
mines ore mines and Waterworks
he looked to his family to fund his
companies his brother Joseph became his
co-partner
Iran trading companies in order to
transport his products
the name tissue became synonymous with
world-class heavy industry
[Music]
Industries
for
many entrepreneurs the age of
industrialization was a golden age
foreign
[Music]
he only allowed himself one luxury
sculptures created by the most famous
sculptor of the turn of the century
in all Algos Tucson bought seven of
August rodan's marble sculptures
[Music]
he was basically not interested in art
in fact he had copies of Dutch Old
Masters on on the walls of Landsberg and
didn't bother to try and buy The
Originals that he could easily have
afforded
Schloss Landsberg in the Hills outside
Essen the home of augustuson
in 1872 Justin married Hedwig Pelzer
daughter of an entrepreneur
despite their affluence they were not a
happy couple
[Music]
this is
after 13 years the couple divorced it
was the children who suffered
Fritz the firstborn son Argos Jr their
son Heinrich and daughter Hedwig
medicine is
the Crown Prince Fritz was destined to
take over the company from his father
his father demanded outstanding results
but was never satisfied with his son
[Music]
is
but Fritz had already met all the
requirements for succeeding his father
of the Helm of the company he had
studied Metallurgy and Engineering both
in Germany and abroad but his father
never gave him credit for it
only once did Fritz go against his
strict father's wishes
the reason for his Disobedience had a
name Amelie to hella
augustuson considered the cologne-born
Emily to be insignificant but Emily was
the love of Fritz's life
Fritz would later recall
in those days we still had dance cards I
filled in my name for every dance on her
card she was content and I was happy
[Music]
foreign
after nine years of marriage their only
child Anita was born
[Music]
on the 4th of April 1926 Augustus passed
away at the age of 83 not only
incredibly rich but also incredibly
lonely
the Empire passed to his sons Fritz and
heinlish Fritz took over the German
steel business while Heinrich was
responsible for the foreign companies in
particular
foreign
there was a lack of male heirs in this
Hungarian aristocratic family and so
Heinrich was adopted by his
father-in-law
from that day on he was known as
heinrichterson bonamisa
Heinrich moved to Switzerland making
Villa Favorita on the banks of Lake
Lugano his family home
Heinrich soon made a name for himself as
an art connoisseur he invested in a
collection that contained works from the
Renaissance to the romantic era
foreign
early summer 1919 delegations from
around the world are negotiating the
Treaty of Versailles fitzsen is also
present as an advisor Fritz Susan
considered the reparations that were
imposed on Germany at the end of World
War One to be deeply humiliating
these reparation payments would later
plunge his country into a deep political
and economic crisis
[Music]
companies trade in arms flourished
during the war abruptly dried up as did
all of its trade with companies outside
Germany
[Music]
foreign
1923 Germany was no longer able to make
its reparation payments French troops
occupied the roar region with a view to
seizing the means of Co and
co-production
none of the industrialists had the
courage to stand up and speak
with the exception of fritzsten who
faced up to the occupying forces on
behalf of the coal and steel sector he
was tried for insubordination in a
French military Court
the threat of a prison sentence that
hung over him was removed as a result of
the protests staged by the workers in
support of their hero Fritz tusson
Fritz's return to duisburg was akin to a
Victory Parade
[Music]
puts act as an employee of Amada and a
fiance is
[Music]
of the Weimar Republic left wing and
right-wing forces were constantly
fighting each other and not only using
democratic means
like many others Fritz tusson expected
much of the budding Ultra right wing
movement
[Music]
is
in 1923 fritzsten gave General
ludendorff a hundred thousand gold marks
ludendorff made a pact with the young
Hitler regarding a punch
[Music]
despite the failure of the attempted
coup in Munich toson maintain ties with
the national socialists these tires were
not only of a professional but of a
personal nature too
the city of mulheim and darua private
films show how idyllic the Tucson family
life really was
[Music]
daughter Anita Learned to Drive
it was a Carefree life and Fritz and
Emily enjoyed it to the fall
Hermann Goering a welcome visitor to the
house was a special friend of the
tussons it was said that Fritz even saw
Gering as a potential husband for his
daughter Anita
also supported the national socialists
financially to allow him to move with
ease in higher circles
[Music]
industry
then they come of these advisory
McNaughton the school repeat this in
contact from Sweden
the 26th of January 1932 a fateful day
for Fritz tusson Hitler addressed the
Dusseldorf industrial Club At Tyson's
invitation around 600 representatives of
the business world were present
dark suit white shirt no visible party
badges Hitler made every effort to
ensure his appearance hit the right note
after all he was looking for donations
which he soon got and not only from
Tucson either
12 months later the dictator was in
power
Fritz tusson's family welcomed the Nazi
regime and on its behalf Fritz wanted to
ensure a more just economic order
um
as one of the most powerful
industrialists in the country Tucson was
given the seat in the reichstag and made
Prussian counselor despite the grand
title his influence was in fact modest
in the summer of 1934 the Nazi party
showed its true colors sa Chief anstron
was arrested removed from his post and
murdered
Hitler even defended the assassination
in public
foreign
[Music]
as the larger shareholder Fritz became
chairman of the supervisory board
he had hardly anything to do with the
day-to-day running of the business
[Applause]
nevertheless the company's senior
managers knew exactly what was happening
with much of the steel It produced
it was being used for semi-finished
products which in turn were used to make
weapons ordered by the German Reich
the wedding of Fritz's daughter Anita
and a Hungarian count in 1936 was not
simply a family affair but a political
incident in addition to Industrial
figures and Aristocrats most of the
guests were dignitaries of the Catholic
Church hardly any Nazis were present
foreign
except the country's political Elite
Berlin had the feeling that Justin was
causing trouble in the eyes of the
regime the industrialist had blotted his
copy book by writing letters of protest
condemning Nazi attacks on Catholic
institutions
some of Justin's personal friends were
now being persecuted by the Nazis
including the hirschlands a Jewish
banking family is
[Music]
1938 the November pogrons
would later recall when on the 9th of
November in the most cowardly and brutal
way the Jews were raided and martyred
and their places of worship destroyed
throughout Germany I once again
submitted a protest
to no avail
it was at this point that Tucson decided
to finally break with the regime
when he was invited to attend an
extraordinary session of the reichstag
in Berlin in the summer of 1939 he knew
what was about to happen
he was in bad Gustin at the time and
sent guring a telegram that read I am
against War
the very next day the wehrmacht invaded
Poland
foreign
Fritz and his family fled to France
through Switzerland
the Flight of the one-time Nazi
supporter caused a sensation abroad
[Music]
[Applause]
in Paris whom do we find but have Fritz
season formerly a great industrial Chief
in Germany and one of the early backers
of Hitler
from the safety of Exile Fritz sought to
make the public aware of what was going
on he wrote letters to Gering and to
Hitler
my only mistake was that I believed in
you our fuhrer Adolf Hitler and in the
movement that you founded
your new policy is suicide your new
policy hair Hitler is driving Germany
into the abyss
[Music]
the apostates provocations were not
without their consequences Fritz and
Amelie were officially deprived of their
nationality all of the family's assets
were confiscated and transferred to a
Nazi Trust
en made sure that his daughter Anita her
husband and son Federico were in safety
they emigrated to Argentina
Fritz and Amelie had every intention of
following them as soon as they had made
some important farewells tussin's 85
year old mother was on her deathbed
undone is Frozen
on the return Journey the couple got
caught up in the German invasion of
France
put in place by the Nazis handed over
Fritz and Emily to the Gestapo later on
Fritz would write
we were brought to a mental institution
near Potsdam no sooner have we arrived
there but I was taken to guring who made
it clear to me that I had two choices
either the People's Court and a certain
death sentence or an appeal for Mercy to
Hitler in the latter case all my assets
will be returned to me and I would be
interned in my father's former house
[Music]
refused to appeal to Hitler for mercy
in 1943 he was sent to a concentration
camp
us is
Fritz and Amelie were interned with what
were known as special prisoners and
those in turn because of the activities
of other members of their families
[Music]
foreign
were in a concentration camp
but not everyone in the Tucson family
sympathize with the prisoners after all
They too had been affected by the
expropriation of assets
images
Fritz's brother Heinrich Tucson bonamisa
had been living in Switzerland since
1932. he could not or would not help his
brother
Heinrich was doing business with the
German rice and held stakes in a number
of companies such as brema Volcan which
supplied the material needed for the
unrestricted U-Boat War
e against
foreign
it was later claimed that Heinrich
rejected an offer made by Nazi
negotiators to exchange his brother for
a number of valuable paintings
[Music]
thank you
and chief sits in this unfreshedness
the politician is
in April 1945 American troops were
stationed near Dachau the famous inmates
were moved out of the camp under no
circumstances did the Nazis want them to
fall into the hands of The Americans
foreign
luck was on their side with the help of
a few Verma Soldiers the SS officers
were forced to give up
on the 4th of May 1945 Fritz and Amelie
were liberated by American troops
foreign
but the 71 year old made it through with
the help of his wife
[Music]
um
liberated he might be but Fritz turson's
Odyssey was not yet over as a former
patron of Hitler the Allied Judiciary
now investigated the extent of his guilt
[Music]
spent three years in an Allied prison
before his case came to trial
one piece of evidence used against him
was a book published by the journalist
Emery Reeves in the USA
I paid Hitler by fritzsten
the book project which Justin and Reeves
initiated in 1940 was completed without
his authorization
it was not only the title of the book
that was used as evidence against the
defendant but Tucson was able to
convince the court that his support for
Hitler had actually not been as great as
claimed in the book
in the end he was sentenced to pay an
expiation fine and deemed less
incriminated
[Music]
at this time Fritz's niece Margaret was
also up in court
she was a witness in a separate case
heinrichterson bornemis's daughter owned
Schloss reshnitz a castle on the border
between Austria and Hungary the estate
was requisitioned by the SS towards the
end of the war
on the 24th of March 1945 a train
carrying forced laborers arrived in
reshnitz it contained 200 Hungarian Jews
who were destined to help build a line
of defenses on the Eastern Front
on the same evening local senior Nazis
and members of the gestapa were holding
a party at Schloss reshnitz
as Lady of the castle Margot was also
present
this is
judicial s
protein and other henchmen left the
party to shoot the Jewish workers under
cross-examination Margaret denied
knowing anything about the execution
to this day no Mass grave has ever been
found in or around reshnitz
however there are witnesses that
poditsin and his men did indeed commit
murder that night
Margaret went on the record as saying
that she only heard about the massacre
on the following day
is quoted as saying I was told that Jews
had been shot during the night
approximately two kilometers from our
Castle
in 2007 a British author went public
with some shocking allegations
he claimed that Margaret shared
responsibility for the executions that
she shot some of the Jews herself the
German press went one step further
tussin's daughter was betrayed as the
hostess of Hell a blood smeared Countess
and the execution of the Jews as party
entertainment but the experts disagree
does Saint kainasia use this
is daughter
does
is foreign
[Music]
nevertheless there is no question that
she had close ties to the murderers
after the war the Allies wanted to
de-industrialize the country the Tucson
industrial complex was also earmarked
for dismantling so that the money from
the sale could be used to pay
compensation to the victors
had not yet been given his assets back
there was no longer anything to keep him
in Germany
foreign
in January 1950 Fritz and Amelie sailed
to Argentina to be with their daughter
and their grandchildren
um
[Music]
foreign
the footsterson did not live to see the
restitution of his assets he died at the
age of 77 on the 8th of February in
1951.
in the early 1950s the Tucson Works
looked as good as new
Chandra artenauer paid a visit to the
workers in duisburg in 1955. he had
organized the political assistance
needed for reconstruction
and the Chancellor's request the Tucson
erises set up a foundation for the
promotion of science they signed over
approximately one tenth of their Fortune
to the foundation
here front shifted for emilitation
foreign
the two heiresses left the running of
the company to managers who transformed
the Tucson steelworks in duesborg into a
global player
the demand for thin sheets of Steel and
high quality steel was huge production
at Tucson was booming
the years of the German economic Miracle
were like a Second Industrial Revolution
for the managers at Tucson
he's inspired Industries
is
foreign
were also unbelievable
good flight
[Music]
by this time hiney was already married
for the third time
his third wife was a British photo model
the young family lived in Villa jafarita
hello Hello
darling but heine's relationships with
women were complicated
[Music]
he was brought up by this nanny who when
he was 18 was dismissed this was his
secret mother it wasn't just a nanny or
an employee
this was a human being in his life who
was just from one day to the next sort
of said here's your pension we don't
need you anymore
she went off and killed herself which I
think she she it was like tearing her
away from her son
my father was so afraid of you will die
alone and poor
and this haunted him all his life
this fear turned Heinen to a Restless
businessman he manufactured pumps and
egg sorting machines but his billion
dollar group also included Banks
breweries and even an oil trading
business as they had anklished
his office
foreign
[Music]
extended his father's collection
Barrington was the most important
private collector in the world whenever
you have a collector buying on that
scale he becomes a taste maker there's
no question about it and his area of
particular interest was German
expressionist artists so this definitely
had an influence for the market more
than anyone else heinitism was
responsible for the rise in demand for
German expressionists such as norder
Heckle and kirschner but he became known
not only as a collector of great Masters
but also of beautiful women we once said
you know the great thing about art is I
can hang my works on the wall which I
can't do with with women and they don't
talk back
but Heine found it difficult to keep
good resolutions his fifth wife was Tita
the Widow of Lex Barker heinies
lifestyle calmed down once Teeter took
control of things
[Music]
um
in 1987 the 66 year old decided to put
his legacy in order and to donate his
unique collection to the public its
value was estimated to be somewhere in
the region of 2 billion Deutsche marks
The Collection was given to Spain his
wife's native country in 1992 the Tucson
bonamisa museum opened in Madrid one of
the biggest attractions in the Spanish
capital
from an early stage Heine had also taken
steps to ensure the survival of the
business Empire
in 1983 he had founded a moniker-based
Family Trust for his children
and put his eldest son Georg heinlich in
charge of running it
[Music]
of the kinds
activities
a few years later having suffered
several Strokes highness and bonamisa
was a man marked by illness
[Music]
was at this point that his wife Tita
took over the reins
although the family trusts business
activities which were managed by heine's
son were generally doing well they were
not performing consistently
on some occasions the agreed dividends
could not be paid out in full to the
father Tita took matters into her own
hands complaining to the press that
Georg Heinrich wants to take everything
away from us money and companies in
January 1997 Heine instructed his
lawyers to sue the Family Trust she was
always very afraid of letting anybody
that she did not control anywhere near
him and that included me and and that
was very sad
thank you
my father really was led to believe that
he wasn't he was left alone and she told
them all the time you know nobody cares
about you anymore and it was so not true
the court case in the Bermudas lasted
almost two years for the lawyers the
dispute surrounding the Legacy was a
gold mine as it was for the Press too
foreign
it was all about too much money in 2001
the presiding judge decided that enough
was enough as far as he was concerned
the sums of money that were being wasted
on the case were simply obscene he
resigned in protest the court case
ground to a halt yeah
slowly killing him and I think that we
really needed to
push forward an agreement because we
wanted him to if he died you know that
he knew that we were all you know back
together again
the children eventually gave in an
out-of-court settlement was reached in
2002. the company stayed under Georg
heinrich's control the family home and
much more went to Tita
foreign
come from the river
the forfeit distance descendants in
Argentina too the Legacy remains a
burden
the fruit is called this rhyme
in 1995 the zichitisens left the company
as the last remaining descendants of the
company's founder involved
today after the merger with crop
augustuson's life work is a global
technology and materials company
employing over 170 000 people
the last grandson of the company founder
died in April 2002 only a few weeks
after the end of the family dispute
with the death of this great art
collector the curtain came down on the
Tucson drama
when Heine was buried in the family
crypt at Schloss Landsberg he was laid
to rest alongside his ancestors
it was augustuson's wish that Schloss
Landsberg would remain the seat of his
dynasty
but his legacy tore his dynasty apart
only in death where they reunited
[Music]
foreign